hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren ich arbeite heute einen Tag lang
bei McDonald's
herzlich willkommen bei McDonald's Ihre
Bestellung bitte
sag mir das bei euch auch
irgendwie sagen die das in jedem
McDonald's genau gleich ne das hier ist
der McDonald's Simulator meine Damen und
Herren wir haben hier die Pommes wir
haben hier juices also Säfte wir haben
hier Cola hier vorne haben wir chicken
die sehen aus wie Avocados
[Musik]
der Sekunde hallo schönen guten Tag der
hat irgendwie keinen Mund wo soll er das
denn Essen der will Fried Chicken Brot
Pommes und so oder
raus
[Musik]
das ging jetzt nicht direkt okay der
nächste Kunde ist direkt da ist der
policeman hat auch kein irgendwie sieht
jeder Polizist in solchen amerikanischen
Sachen genau gleich ausmachen direkt der
nächste Kunde Brot und schicken will der
Kriege von der Zeit
[Musik]
jetzt ganz konzentriert
hallo anrufen ich glaube wir müssen als
erstes ein Tablet nehmen ihm
[Musik]
schon wieder weg nimm das Tablett so
also Fried Chicken Soda und juice okay
nehmen wir hier vorne so darauf wie kann
ich das denn öffnen
wie kann ich irgendwer nehmen wir
probieren also kann ich jetzt chicken
genau nicht
vielleicht muss ich aber auch das
Tabletten nehmen und damit hier hin okay
das geht vielleicht schicken jetzt
will der Typ kein schicken kommt nimm
das einfach
nimm doch einfach chicken du kriegst
kostenlos herzlich willkommen bei
McDonald's Ihre Bestellung bitte
[Musik]
sehr schön der Herr Brad okay nehmen wir
erstmal ein Brot wo ist dein Brot ja
hier ist Brot so ein Brot möchte haben
oder möchte er haben also hier vorne
eine Flasche Soda dann möchte der auch
noch frei also Pommes guck mal der will
alles haben ne eine Packung Pommes dann
möchte er
[Musik]
ich weiß jetzt wie es geht
und werde den nächsten Tag komplett
rasieren ein Tag später
geöffnet
[Musik]
Ihre Bestellung bitte Preis juice bread
und Soda okay Fries juice Soda und Brad
bitte schön
[Musik]
dieses Spiel kostet 2,99 € und es macht
mir echt eine Menge Spaß hallo Brigitte
da bist ja wieder alles klar Brigitte
willst du auch noch die Bank gekauft oh
das geht aber richtig schnell der wollte
aber alles ne Preis oder Ding ich weiß
jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau ich hoffe
mal Brot okay
[Musik]
ich bin so ein Gigi der will auch alles
haben also chicken Pommes tschüss Soda
und hier vorne auch noch mal ein Brot
bitte schön die Sache ist allerdings ihr
seht schon dass die Brote hier weniger
werden logischerweise auch das schicken
und die ganzen anderen Sachen deshalb
haben wir natürlich hier hinten auch
eine Küche da können wir
moin Birgit Soda Bread juice Fries Soda
Brad
juice Fries kommen ganz
oh mein Gott gerade noch so mitgenommen
da ist er wieder frei Soda und Fried
Chicken Fried Chicken Rice Soda
oh nein hallo Meister wie geht's dir
alles klar
Soda juice red Preis Soda juice
vielleicht wäre es sinnvoller wenn ich
mir einfach nur die Sachen die er nicht
haben will merke er will zum Beispiel
jetzt alles haben dann nehmen wir auch
wieder so ein Ding zack zack zack zack
zack die Frage ist jetzt nur was mache
ich wenn das alles leer ist ist dann
hier was drin weil hier in den Boxen ich
hier so hinstellen das sind ja auch guck
mal er will nur so da haben ich habe
auch irgendwann keine Tablette mehr oder
oder werden die immer dann dahin gepackt
hier mal zack sind auch Sachen drin das
sind alles nur Boxen kann ich hier durch
kann ich auch nicht Boxen Boxen was soll
ich denn mit den Boxen
der will alles haben ganz schnell ganz
schnell zack zack zack zack zack ich
hoffe das kriege ich noch hin seid läuft
ab sehr gut der Polizist natürlich
wieder mit am Start der will alles haben
außer Soda und jetzt habe ich halt keine
Pommes mehr ich weiß jetzt nicht ob das
irgendwie
ein Problem ist aber wenn jetzt einer
Pommes haben will was soll ich denn dann
machen ich kann noch mal kurz schauen ob
hier nicht irgendwas ist aber die
meinten im Tutorial dass da irgendwie
auch eine Küche sein
ja ich habe kein Brot
was soll ich jetzt machen zehn Stunden
später
[Applaus]
Entschuldigung der Herr Lutz muss kurz
nach hinten gehen bitte Essen auffüllen
also das hier machen wir jetzt auch mal
kurz wieder voll dann nehmen wir uns von
hier vorne noch mal eine Kiste und
machen jetzt auch ganz kurz die Preis
wieder voll aber jetzt erstmal wieder
hier die Kunden bedienen der möchte
alles haben also zack zack zack zack
zack und zack und F perfekt jetzt hier
wieder nehmen warten Soda Bread und
juice so oder juice und Brad
bitte schön jetzt sehen wir mal hier
vorne ein paar Kisten mit würde ich
sagen und füllen mal eben schnell alles
wieder auf weil auch hier vorne das und
okay den nehmen wir erstmal ganz kurz
bread der will nur ein Brot haben
wahrscheinlich braucht man deswegen
jetzt McDonald's kommt aber bitte schön
noch eine Box mit und packen da vorne
rein wir haben auch gleich keine Box
mehr dann ist ja die Frage ob das Spiel
einfach vorbei ist müssen uns auch mal
merken vielleicht können wir das ja auch
noch irgendwie geben wenn er genau das
haben will oder vielleicht schick und
Fries oder Fred chicken ah nee ist kein
sola äh Soda Fries Fried Chicken die
Sache ist ich habe übelsten Hunger Event
in Düsseldorf habt ihr vielleicht meine
Instagram Story gesehen guck mal der
wird alles haben da können wir jetzt
aber das hier einfach nehmen und packen
einfach noch das mit dazu und so oder
dann haben wir das auch entsor
nix bitte weggeschmissen ich war gerade
auf jeden Fall auf dem Event und habe
einfach so ein übelsten Hunger und ich
dachte mir komm ich nehme jetzt
zumindest noch eben schnell so ein Video
auf ist jetzt nicht krass geschnitten
aber hat gerade Bock hier auf so einen
essensspiel weil ich halt so ein Hunger
hungrig Einkaufen einfach alles der wird
alles außer Brot haben sehr gut ich auch
nicht nehmen so eine tote Scheibe Toast
Alter ist die Toast getoastet oder so
[Musik]
also Menschen die das so essen das muss
so leicht angetastet sein und dann
schwimmen Nutella drauf
abgestürzt
perfekt
einfach der beste Youtuber da würde ich
direkt mal ein Abo da lassen nein